ah
Charles Kesler is the dangler Dyke my
distinguished professor of government at
Claremont McKenna College he served as
director of the Claremont Colleges Henry
Salvatori Center for the Study of
individual freedom in the modern world
from 1989 to 2008 he is editor of the
well-known Claremont Review of Books and
a senior fellow of the Claremont
Institute for the Study of statesmanship
and political philosophy his edition of
the Federalist Papers which I know well
is this politics student I was published
by Cigna classic by penguin Pittman and
is the best-selling edition in the
country he is the editor of and a
contributor to saving the revolution the
Federalist Papers and the American
founding and has written extensively on
American constitutionalism and American
political thought he is co-editor with
the late William F Buckley Jr of keeping
the tablets modern American conservative
thought his articles on contemporary
politics have appeared in The Wall
Street Journal the Christian Science
Monitor policy review National Review
the Weekly Standard and other journals
he is the author most recently of an
excellent book which might be the best
book on our current President Barack
Obama and the fourth wave of liberalism
please join me in welcoming dr. Charles
Kesler
thank you very much Penelope it's always
a great pleasure and a privilege to be
here speaking for Hillsdale and before
such a distinguished group of men and
women am i leaving anyone out
and I'm delighted also to to be here to
help to celebrate the continued
prosperity of the Kirby Center here in
Washington DC it's a fitting extension
it seems to me of hills dales efforts
under president Arne to to teach the US
Constitution and to focus attention on
and off the campus on the question of
what has happened to our Constitution in
the last hundred years in particular as
the notion of the that progressive what
the progressives called the living
Constitution has come to eclipse the
actual written constitution it's true
that Larry and I go back a long way he
is of course much much older than I am
but I was very young when I began when I
arrived in Claremont penny looks
completely unchanged though it perhaps
more beautiful than ever
and Larry looks
very much like himself I think but it's
always good to be with them and to have
a chance to talk about old times and new
times well the occasion of our meeting
today is Constitution Day which for your
sticklers was Monday September 17th
celebrating the the day that the
Constitution was reported out of the
Constitutional Convention but for
liberals every day is Constitution day
living Constitution day especially if
the Supreme Court is in session by the
way I asked for an empty chair to be
placed up here what what happened what
happened to my prop I didn't prepare any
remarks but I thought no well the title
of my book on that addresses these
subjects is I am the change Barack Obama
and the crisis of liberalism and
obviously the speed that the title is or
an attempt at a play on words with
designed to bring out barack obama's
louis xiv side they toss them wha I am
the state I think Obama is I am the
change you know and he actually came
very close to saying something precisely
like that and close enough you know to
be exploited there were other titles
that we considered for this book but we
decided against them my one of my
favorites was suggested by my friend
Bill vocally Barack Obama what the hell
were we thinking
and then more recently though I came up
with this idea which for some reason the
publisher rejected Fifty Shades of
Barack Obama I don't know I think that
would have sold I'm not sure but as
against many of my friends in the
conservative movement I I don't think
it's that helpful to try to understand
Obama differently initially then he
understands himself I think it it's both
fair and necessary that we tried to meet
him on his own ground and what I tried
to do in this book is by reading his
speeches his interviews his books and
those of many liberals before him to put
him in the context of American
liberalism one could call him a
socialist and many writers on the
conservative side do but it's hard he
doesn't call himself a socialist and
it's hard to call him if you call him a
socialist for wanting to raise the upper
tax bracket to 39% and change what would
you call FDR who raised it to 79% and
who put inheritance taxes at 70% at the
top marginal rate if Barack Obama is a
socialist in that sense then many
leading liberals of the past century
would be even more socialistic than he
nor do I think of course that you one
gets very far in trying to understand
him as a as a foreigner or as a closeted
Muslim or anything like that and I even
disagree with my old friend Dinesh
D'Souza who tries to understand him as a
as a third-world ideologue as a kind of
you know anti-colonialist who inherited
the these strange ideas from his Kenyan
father the the problem with that I think
is that it suggests that there's
something uniquely bad about Obama that
if he hadn't had a
and father he'd be perfectly okay if he
hadn't encountered anti-colonialism he
would be okay but in fact you know
anti-colonialism I don't think explains
national healthcare the stimulus bill
dodd-frank all all of the signature
achievements of his administration on
which he was backed by every Liberal
Democrat in the Congress
none of whom had Kenyan fathers so it
seems to me one has to begin by
understanding Obama as he understands
himself as a liberal as a progressive
and that's what I try to do but it's
harder to understand what it means to be
a liberal anymore and so in what I do in
my book is to put between two covers
that the story of modern liberalism from
Woodrow Wilson to the present and to try
to tell Obama's place in that story and
his significance in that story which is
I think very large for many decades the
American Republic didn't know what had
hit it after liberalism began to spread
in our politics about a hundred years
ago conservatives in particular have had
a very hard time understanding their
opponent of trying to figure out who or
what it was that conservatives are
opposing I'll just mention some of the
different ways that conservatives have
understood the left in America or
liberalism in America some conservative
one in particular Richard Weaver used to
argue that liberalism came out of a form
of medieval nominalism out of you know
something 900 years ago Russell Kirk and
others argue that our liberalism is a
continuation of the French Revolution
something from several centuries ago as
well a few conservatives
have maintained that it's liberalism
originates in the regimental spirit of
industrialization and that we'd all be
better off becoming agrarians again more
conservatives and more even well-known
conservatives have argued that it that
Abraham Lincoln was the first liberal
and that he and the anti-slavery caused
their universalism somehow gave birth to
the modern state and of course there
have been a few stout conservatives over
the years who have argued that
liberalism is the work of Satan this is
the the church-lady school but it's also
something that you know Whittaker
Chambers really is it's a big theme of
Whittaker Chambers book that that
liberalism emerges from the desire to
want to replace God in our life and
there's some truth to that and there's
some truth to at least a couple of these
explanations but obviously I would say
none of them is adequate but our trouble
conservatives trouble with identifying
our opponents is echoed on the left
because liberals also have trouble
explaining their movements and
explaining their purposes if you read
books by liberals about liberalism of
which let me tell you there are quite a
few them you'll find that the most
popular explanation of liberalism today
by liberals is that it's nothing but the
spirit of bold persistent
experimentation this is a phrase from
FDR President Obama quoted it just a few
weeks ago in his second acceptance
speech that is his acceptance speech in
of this year bold persistent
experimentation in other words
liberalism is nothing but pragmatism the
desire to find out what works in order
to cure our social problems liberalism
is completely if you believe them uh
Nydia logical even unthreat achill in
fact it's downright conservative because
all it's trying to do is adjust our
political arrangements to keep them in
sync with our
economic and political progress and
social progress if you listen to
liberals its conservatives who are the
ideologue they have theories like
trickle-down economics or originalism
you know when it comes to how to
interpret the Constitution now the
Liberals modest account of themselves is
of course self-interested it's designed
to insulate them from charges of
radicalism that would emerge if they
actually began to talk about their own
doctrines they use evolution to describe
or I'm sorry to disguise revolution the
account they give themselves is like the
policeman who says keep moving there's
nothing to see here keep moving
don't look at the thing you want to look
at and which is so obvious and so their
favorite account to themselves under
this Nostrum of the living Constitution
they present is a merely a modest you
know adaptive evolutionary change
designed to keep the Constitution alive
and relevant because the alternative to
their living Constitution is a dead
Constitution that's their argument a
constitution that belongs to a world the
eighteenth century that is dead and gone
to use justice brennan's famous phrase
if if you want to have a dead
Constitution like the Conservatives or
argue you can but if you want to have a
living Constitution then you have to
follow the liberal mode of interpreting
it but this false modesty doesn't hide
the fact that liberals also speak of
their vision their values and most
revealingly of the transformation that
they'd seek in American politics one of
Barack Obama's few memorable lines was
you know just before the election when
he said we're five days away from
fundamentally transforming the United
States of America he didn't say into
what
liberals never do they keep a studied
ambiguity about what they want us to
become but they sure don't want us to
stay what we are or return to what we
were that much is clear now as a
political phenomenon American liberalism
it seems to me is best understood by
following the the the history of the
United States and our political history
of our political contests as a political
phenomenon it's it's exactly a hundred
years old
it emerged in the progressive movement
that broke into our politics in the 1912
election the election won by Woodrow
Wilson it propagated itself in our
politics in three waves the new freedom
associated with Wilson of course the New
Deal and then the Great Society along
with its tragic chorus the new left now
each of these waves set out to transform
America as the name suggested if you
want to make a Great Society the
implication is the existing society is a
lousy one a New Deal implies you need
that the old deal is obsolete or unfair
and the new freedom not the new birth of
freedom that Abraham Lincoln talked
about but the new freedom means the old
is obsolete
you must start again somehow in our
politics that means that Obama's
apparent fourth wave of liberal activism
is only the latest installment of this
fundamental desire this drive to
fundamentally change our politics now it
ought to encourage us that each one of
these prior waves of liberalism was
stopped in its tracks eventually you
know by 1920 progressivism was over it
was a spent force by 1936 or at the
latest 1938 the New Deal was finished as
an active reform movement doctor when
the war had replaced dr. new
as FDR like to put it and of course in
the 1960s the Great Society which didn't
begin to till late 1963 when Lyndon
Johnson succeeded the slain President
Kennedy was effectively over by about
1966 or 67 so each each wave only lasted
a few years they can be stopped but we
should be chastened by the knowledge
that this transformative process started
again a generation later in every case
liberalism apparently can be stopped but
not for long
in 2010 the voters stopped for a Barack
Obama's transformation I mean he's
really got nothing much done since 2010
but he succeeded in pushing through in
the first two years that he was in
office a great deal we don't know
whether he's now stopped and liberalism
is on in stasis mode again that will be
determined in large part by the election
coming up but all told if you look at
now the last hundred years the 20th
century was very much what my late
friend Tom silver liked to call the
liberal century remember that
conservatism didn't arrive on the scene
of our politics until late in that
century its major victories were very
late Ronald Reagan in 1980 Newt Gingrich
taking the house in 1994 I mean the
century was four fifths over before
conservatism really began to assert
itself in politics conservatism didn't
even appear until the first two waves of
liberalism had done their work
conservatism starts in the 1950s one
could say the mid 1950s National Review
was founded in 1955 so liberals had
already transformed America and American
politics to some extent before
conservatism even got into the game
before it began to be opposed now all of
the alluvial silt from the stream
of liberalism over the past century
deposited itself in Barack Obama's
formation the crisis of liberalism is
Obama's crisis and so rather than as I
actually do in in my book explaining and
criticizing each stage of liberalism I
thought it better just to concentrate on
Obama's or mainly concentrate on Obama's
own appropriation of them and there
certainly from his point of view plenty
to be said about what liberalism means
and what it aims at to begin with he
calls himself a progressive he said so
in the 2008 campaign as did Hillary
Clinton both of them were running away
from the liberal label switching back to
the original label of progressive what
do progressives believe in 1912 or in
2012 well if you believe Woodrow Wilson
and you can always read RJ post Rito's
excellent book on Woodrow Wilson as a
guide progressives literally believe in
the inevitability of human progress and
by literally I mean literally as opposed
to what most speakers mean when they say
literally figuratively
now they literally believed in the
inevitability of human progress and that
and this is very important that moral
and political progress went hand-in-hand
with technological and scientific
project progress I mean we all sort of
believe in infinite scientific progress
that's possible you know you never know
everything but the notion that human
beings and their politics are
perfectible is very is a very different
contention I think most sensible people
including the founders thought that
those two things did not advance in
perfect harmony could not advance in
perfect harmony because man's nature is
not in fact perfectible I mean we can
make progress towards its perfection but
we never can arrive at human perfection
you can
ever expect as Hamilton said perfect
work perfect a perfect work from the
hands of imperfect man and I think
that's a very conservative way of
looking at human nature but liberals
think that human progress is inevitable
because of a new doctrine or discovery
concerning history that history has a
mind of its own and it has a destination
in that mind and that all events
cooperate toward realizing that destiny
as as RJ could explain Hegel the German
philosopher Hegel was the greatest
proponents of this view of philosophy of
history in in the nineteenth century and
I could say fortunately that American
liberalism has more of Hegel in it than
of his disciple and critic Karl Marx and
were very lucky that American liberalism
is not is evolutionary and not
revolutionary because there's were two
streams from a common source but let me
offer two quotations one old and one new
that I think helped to characterize this
attitude of progressivism when he was
the president of Princeton University
Woodrow Wilson said something to
students that he repeated when he was
running for the Presidency in 1912 and
he put it between the covers of his book
the new freedom the collected speeches
or edited speeches of that year and as
president University he is strictly
speaking comparable to Larry Arne and so
if you know one could not imagine Larry
Arn saying this but the fact that
Woodrow Wilson proclaimed it repeated it
in politics highlighted it in a way
tells you all you need to know about the
difference between liberalism and
conservatism what Wilson said was his
objective at Princeton the objective of
college education ought to be to make
the sons as much unlike their fathers as
possible
now just think about that to make the
sons as unlike their fathers as possible
not because the fathers weren't splendid
fellows and not to be sure because
Wilson was averse to cashing their sons
tuition checks but because the father's
necessarily belong to a world that was
dying and the sons belong to a better
world a new world that was a dawning if
you take that as your educational goal
then it implies a complete Rhian
orientation of moral and political
studies from devotion to what had what
had been fought and said and done in the
best instances in the past to the drama
of a better essentially unprecedented
world to come
that's why liberals have never been so
interested in history history describes
human nature as we knew it
not human nature as it will be in the
future and it's oh it's no guide for us
now to look back and see the failures or
even the successes of the past the only
way to properly study the past from a
progressive point of view was an
anticipation of something much grander
to come compared to the future Wilson
said the present is as nothing the past
he implied was less than nothing it's ok
one could say to study Abraham Lincoln
so long as you treat him as Barack
Obama's prefiguration that's in effect
what that means now the American
founders by contrast viewed the great
figures of the past more or less as
contemporaries because they didn't think
that human nature changed at their best
the founders tried at least to
understand the past as it had understood
itself before trying to understand it
differently
better so you know many of the founders
studied ancient languages Hebrew as well
as modern languages and they had a deep
acquaintance with those texts
Jefferson's letters Adams as letters are
full of snippets of Greek ancient Greek
and Latin and occasionally even Hebrew
as well as French and a little bit of
Italian in other words these were not
parochial men these were men who had
studied the past because they thought
they could learn something from it
not just something about it but our
president today who considers himself as
you know a citizen of the world speaks
one language English
that's his cosmopolitanism but he
doesn't feel like he has to confront the
past or study the past because the
assumption is because of progressivism
we come later therefore we see better
and farther and are wiser than any that
came before when when Woodrow Wilson
argued against what he called blind
worship of the Constitution what he
meant really was we should not have any
kind of veneration for so so old and
obsolete a doctoral document and that
generation applied this principle of
progress to religion just as ruthlessly
as they did to education and to politics
so when Obama says he believes in the
living Constitution as he does in the
his second book The Audacity of Hope
he's using a phrase and an idea that
comes that is a hundred years old that
comes especially from a from Woodrow
Wilson and the term living Constitution
is a very attractive one for the left
it sounds so natural so green
so organic just like there's highly
touted foods in the supermarket that
charge extra for the wormholes but this
this naturalistic connotation or
implication is a deliberate misdirection
because the idea of the living
Constitution doesn't stand or fall by
natural selection its principle is
artificial selection the logic of it is
look we have evolved to the point where
now we understand evolution and we can
control it from here on we can control
our own evolution we can take charge of
society's development as well in other
words the living Constitution is not
some less a fair slogan you know let the
Constitution grow as it naturally would
no it's a mandate for experts scientists
to take charge of government and to
experiment on the formerly sovereign
people rather than simply represent them
it's a mandate to build a new state and
breed as it were a better people the
living Constitution is really
constitutional eugenics so amid the
seeming flux of the living Constitution
which everything all institutions and
practices are up for change following
the Darwinian law of life as liberals
will tell you it's surprising to find
that some things are permanent and
here's my second quotation from
President Obama speaking about his
health care bill quote I am NOT the
first president to take up this cause he
told Congress in September 2009 but I am
determined to be the last in other words
he considers his law to be progressive
and progress to be irreversible
it's one cannot turn back the clock
once you have
Social Security Medicare Medicaid
Obamacare once you have these
fundamental new programs to vindicate
new social and economic rights there's
no going back the fact that they may be
unconstitutional is no argument against
them
because the living Constitution is the
real Constitution if you to appeal to
the written constitution against
something like Obamacare would be from
the liberal point of view
unconstitutional you can't do that the
living Constitution is more
authoritative than the old Constitution
because it's designed to replace it so
Obamacare does mark a triumph of
liberalism no doubt about it I think
alone it would qualify Obama's face for
the liberal Mount Rushmore
more specifically Obamacare is of course
a triumph for entitlement rights one of
the new deals lasting contributions to
liberalism and these new kinds of rights
imply a whole new view of the social
contract if you look at FDR and look at
his Commonwealth Club address in 1932
probably his most theoretical or
philosophical speech he explains what
this new contract consists of there he
says that the contract is between the
people and their rulers not among
individuals who have pre-existing rights
from nature or from God but a contract
between the people and their rulers in
which the people give the rulers power
in exchange for the rulers giving them
rights in other words the more powerful
you make government the more rights it
can give you all kinds of welfare rights
regulatory waivers all of our liberties
come from the government choosing not to
govern us not choosing to exempt us from
its Authority in other words the social
contract as the Liberals now explain it
is very much more like Magna Carta than
it is
the Declaration of Independence and this
leads to what I call the first law of
big government there's no reason to fear
government no matter how big it gets our
strong it gets because the more power it
has the more rights it can grant to us
and the this sinister implication of
course is that if our rights are
dependent upon government why shouldn't
we be but of course someone has to pay
for these rights these new rights free
speech doesn't really cost anything but
a right to health care sure does every
right implies a duty but welfare state
duties are both vague and vaguely
assigned who pays for the hospital rooms
and procedures and the doctor's time
that the right to health care requires
who pays for the job that is guaranteed
to every American under the liberal
dispensation and the the left has been
extremely slippery in answering that
question sometimes they say well of
course everyone pays because it's like
social insurance you pay your you pay
the premium and then you get the benefit
at the end but of course it's not a
secret that most people receive much
more than they contributed to the
program and if a few people do that's
that's okay that's called insurance but
if everybody receives more that can't
work as insurance and so the left soon
changes their tune and says well it's
actually the rich who are going to pay
we're going to tax them at higher rates
spread the wealth around and the result
will be we can fund all of the promises
of the welfare state but that doesn't
work either as we are quickly finding
out and this problem the problem that
the state can make can manufacture many
more promises
than it can possibly pay for is that the
root of liberalism's fiscal implosion we
see it beginning in Europe we see the
harbingers of it in our own case and the
cause is as mrs. Thatcher pointed out
long ago you quickly run out of other
people's money finally President Obama
is a child of the 60s literally he was
born in 1961 to an interracial couple
his father was mm-hmm
a Kenyan a socialist and
anti-colonialist and and that much of
Dinesh's
argument is undeniable his mother was a
dreamy flower child who eventually
earned a doctorate in cultural
anthropology probably the most left-wing
of all left-wing disciplines in the
Academy and her advisor in her PhD
program was John Dewey's granddaughter
as they say you can't make this stuff up
now before Obama the 1960s ran until the
1980s or until the success of Ronald
Reagan became clear as a young man Obama
suffered a kind of 60s Envy after all
him he was too young he missed out on
the civil rights movement and the new
left but he was determined to experience
them vicariously and as a young man he
sort of replayed the 60s in his own life
he tried drugs you know not just
marijuana but cocaine he rallied against
South Africa he community organized he
gave and delighted in giving political
speeches and tried to get in touch with
the black experience in America I mean
he joined Reverend Wright's church for
political reasons but also because he
wanted to experience something he hadn't
experienced before the black church so
in general you could say as he says that
he was searching for meaning something
that is very
a kind of sixties existential theme but
he also shared the civil rights
movements determination to make history
rather than to let it happen or to trust
it to redeem injustice in the long run
in its own good time and when also
detects in Obama stirrings of
post-modernism the notion that universal
values a phrase he does use from time to
time even universal truths he speaks
about occasionally are not universal and
probably not true in any objective sense
one can see these ideas at work in
Dreams from My Father the heavily
fictionalized autobiography that he
wrote now politicians are notoriously
untruthful let's grant that but nope no
future president ever boasted that he
was making stuff up in order to tell his
story better in other words in order to
tell his story the way he wanted to tell
it but Obama does he tells you in the
beginning of dreams for my father that
this is not all true that he's combined
characters that he's invented incidents
that he's rearranged chronology in other
words it's a very postmodern biography
it's a it's a book about not his real
self or his historical self but his self
created self it's Obama as he ought to
be or at least as he wants to present
himself to us and this motive covers of
course covering up several inconvenient
truths about his own upbringing for
example you know the this black
communists Frank Marshall Davis you've
all heard about probably in one way or
another who is referred to in the book
simply as Frank and never identified
with his actual political vocation or
the incident that Obama cleverly alludes
to in the book but
only Stanley Kurtz tracked down namely
that Obama when he was a student at
Columbia attended at Cooper Union the
Democratic socialists of America
conference celebrating the 100th
centenary of the death of Karl Marx I
guess it would have been better if we
would in worse if it was the 100th
anniversary of the birth of Karl Marx
but still it's an interesting
biographical fact that was unreported
until last year at any rate we begin to
see where Obama goes beyond
old-fashioned liberalism began that
beyond the creed of Woodrow Wilson or
Franklin Roosevelt Obama doubts or comes
close to doubting the inevitability of
progress partly because he doubts that
there are fixed goal posts or standards
by which to measure progress the profit
leader as it were the great hero figure
of liberal politics the the charismatic
leader that liberals all long for is
therefore on his own if there's no such
thing as progress that he can ride along
on and foresee the profit leader is
forced to tell stories about the future
that a future he cannot know or discern
anymore but can only if his will to
power is sufficiently strong will into
existence if history has no happy ending
in store no guaranteed values of its own
then the leader may have no choice but
to impose his values on the chaos thus
the the second half of liberalism's
crisis the first is fiscal the second
philosophical avant-garde liberals
especially in the Academy tend no longer
to believe liberalism is true or right
in any objective sense
fortunately our president is not a
thoroughgoing postmodernist but his
confusion about whether there is truth
combined with the traditional liberal
impatience with the
Constitution makes for a very harrowing
combination and so we ought to remember
that not every change is an improvement
a movement that began by promising to
every American a new freedom and a new
deal
beyond necessity' sness now runs from
the necessity of paying its own bills a
movement that promised complete
spiritual fulfillment in a great society
including the right to choose one's own
values and lifestyle now verges on
confessing that no lifestyle can be said
to be better than any other and the
movement that put such faith in its
leaders ability to understand predict
and control the future now faces a very
uncertain and perilous future with or
without Barack Obama this is why of
course the election of 2012 is so
important the constitutionality of the
modern state and the grounds of our own
equality and Liberty are at stake in
this election as never before so on the
occasion of Constitution day let us
rededicate ourselves to the perpetuation
of our actual Constitution the Republic
and its way of life thank you
Thank You dr. Kessler we now have time
for a few questions if you'd like to ask
a question please raise your hand and
we'll bring the mic to you can vasuki
hear hi very good Charles a voice from
beyond yes I know the voice of God as
they say
what about Obama's record on foreign
policy we think of Wilson and FDR's war
presidents and Obama of course taking us
out of wars but continuing or even
intensifying Bush's national security
policy in many areas so what do you make
of that is that cover for a more radical
domestic policy or did he learn
something when he came into office and
realized he these were necessary
measures well that's a good question
about his foreign policy he certainly
has political reasons to try to shuck
off the bad reputation that liberalism
has for conducting weak foreign policy
one of the reasons why he and Hillary
both go back to the term progressive is
that liberalism is spoiled on foreign
policy questions there helped of course
by the fact that communism collapsed and
so the old distinctions don't have the
vitality they once did but when Obama
writes about foreign policy when he
speaks about foreign policy here occurs
most often to Rosa vote to FDR and to
Roosevelt II in terms he speaks about
the Four Freedoms
for example often when he's talking
foreign policy and I think the decision
to have a more muscular foreign policy
as we say today is in part a principled
decision by him and in part a political
one
I think the on the on the principled
side
he wants to reconnect himself and his
administration to the Roosevelt legacy
of fighting tyrants or at least killing
tyrants but he doesn't he doesn't want
to make that into a hard-and-fast
principle because to do so I think he
thinks would incline him much too much
to puff up the United States and its own
role in the world what separates him
most obviously from FDR is Obama's deep
suspicions that we can actually be a
force for good in the world and so he
here occurs to something like the the
limited or a modified form of FDR's
realism in the interest of a much more
constrained form of idealism but they
have in common of course this dedication
to international organization and norms
I mean FDR presided over the birth of
the United Nations this was his one of
his great final projects and Obama and
his advisors are big believers in all
that I'm not sure that that answer
explains every bit of Obama's foreign
policy because I think the rest of it is
really political calculation on his part
but I do think he has as a citizen of
the world he has some obligations to the
world and he's prepared to use American
military force up to a point to enforce
those obligations
any other questions yes unfortunately we
are out of time so this will be our last
question that's good because I'm out of
answers
I appreciate your description of
liberalism or progressivism as viewing
history is something that should should
not be paid any real attention to except
it seems it puts Obama and others in a
natural dilemma which is they say they
should pay no attention to history
except their own history of
progressivism and why would not for a
truly pragmatic position be that well
maybe it's time to try something
different which could include
conservatism yes this is the problem of
progress it could turn into regress if
if the old truths come around again but
it's it's not quite the case that they
are not interested in history it's just
that they're in their understanding the
wisdom of the past cannot be
authoritative for our situation because
our situation is fundamentally different
and better than it was in the past and
so if you think about the slogan which
Woodrow Wilson's charge to try to make
the sons as little unlike their fathers
as possible naturally leads to namely
trust no one over 30 I mean that's
really the effective teaching of of
Wilson on that matter because it's the
young who know because they are more in
touch with the processes of life with
history with what's coming next
if you take if you take that seriously
it means the abolition of wisdom and
thus of all sources of wisdom from
anyone over 30 I mean not many people
would would ask for a surgeon who's
under 30 you know could you give me the
least-experienced man
that you that you have in the operating
room but that is in effect what
liberalism prescribes for us politically
well thank you very much